foreign
Cincinnati hey Tommy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey thank you guys for having me
gentlemen how are you doing today better
than we deserve sir how can we help
there so I'm just kind of first and
foremost I'm grateful to be on the call
my wife and I uh newly debt free I thank
you guys for your leadership there and
your guidance
um I may or between the two of us we
make roughly 138 thousand dollars per
year I have been in a job I'm 35 years
old for about 15 years with the federal
government I'm working for a government
agency
um and at 30 years
um so at the time I'm 50 I'll be
eligible for a monthly annuity or
pension
um kind of growing up I've heard of my
grandparents having pensions so on and
so forth they obviously uh are doing
well but aside from them I haven't
really encountered anyone with a pension
um so I have this kind of perfect ideal
picture of what it's like to have a
pension
um and especially at the age of 50 you
know just kind of enticing well as of
you're not you're how old now again
I'm 35 years old so okay so 15 more
years okay yep yep
um well today I was just offered uh
another job uh working in the private
sector uh making about 40 to 50 000 warm
uh depending on the bonus but uh an
annual bar excuse me an annual base
salary of about forty thousand dollars
more per year
um and uh just kind of curious you know
which way would you lean on on going
um that would bring our household income
to roughly eighty thousand dollars per
year
I thought you were getting a potential
raise he did 50 000. okay so that's like
130 to 180 right
oh you said oh look I thought you said
80 for a second well so let's move let's
remove the money from the conversation
when you heard about this job
opportunity okay I understand the bump
uh and it's in the private sector but do
you get excited about the actual work
itself and then where it might lead
yes I guess yes and no
um yes and just in terms of doing
something different right I've been
doing uh my current job for 15 years
um on the younger side of things sure um
but really don't know a whole lot else
all right let me ask you this do you
what's your enjoyment level of your
government job right now on a scale of
one to ten one being suck and ten being
you love it
um I would say eight I I I I like it
pretty well so here's the deal number
one I wouldn't stay in any job for any
pension just for the pension the pension
to me would never be the reason I would
stay all right and the good news is you
you got an eight uh that's a pretty high
level of enjoyment most Americans aren't
experiencing an eight in their work so
that's good on the other hand uh you
know going to the private sector with an
opportunity to move up the ladder and
make more money uh I would do that in
regards to just staying for a pension so
you're kind of in this uh middle area
for me there's not a clear winner
because you could take this job the
private sector job make more money uh
even have an opportunity for advancement
but if you don't enjoy the work and it's
just oh I'm doing it because it's
something different let me tell you
something you got about 40 percent of
people who change jobs in the last two
years regret changing their jobs because
the paycheck or off the promotion wore
off and they realized they were better
off where they were and that concerns me
your answer of it's just something
different well once the different weight
wears off now you could be stuck so what
do you do now
um like what agency what's your day job
what's your title what do you do
yeah so I am like a customer service
person uh working for a a state agency
or excuse me a federal agency that helps
with grants so you're in customer
service okay and so you would be doing
what at the new place
um I would be working for a
telecommunications company working with
local municipalities in managing their
contracts
so kind of in the same field
correct yep absolutely
so theoretically you could get a you
could have an eight in on the enjoyment
meter at this at this new job as well
correct
um yeah yeah I think you need to dig in
a little bit more you know because
because it's a no-brainer for me if you
were to tell me that you could enjoy the
private sector job and it provides you a
ladder for Financial and Professional
growth it's a no-brainer to me to take
the Privacy if if you've got if you've
got as good an environment or better
you've got as good a pro a chance of
progressing or better and your level of
enjoyment is as good or better 100 take
the new job yeah
okay because the pension versus 50 Grand
is an easy decision yes you know let's
just say 15 years you're talking about
sitting there waiting on this pension 15
years of 50 Grand is called 750 Grand
that that'll build you a pension my man
for sure for sure self-induced cell
phone self-run self everything and
you'll you know show them you're going
to make a lot more money in the private
sector than your pension would ever even
come close to
um and uh the the you know well it's
secure not listen there's nothing is
there's nothing secure don't your
position is only as secure As You Are
your ability to go get something is your
security and so and you've already
proven that so yeah as long as the
company is solid there's not a bunch of
toxic environment and you're not just
going just for the money the people that
have had the regret went just for the
money and they ignored the other
variables and they stepped in it yep
that's exactly right so they get there
and they realize wait a second uh I was
really excited about the paycheck bump
and maybe a nice new title but uh I
don't enjoy coming into work yeah these
people their their values are screwed up
yeah they may treat you like you're just
a commodity instead of a human being
hello you were able to be purchased
that's a very good point that's a very
good point you you they dangled the
carrot and you went after you if you act
like a commodity then guess what they
might treat you like a commodity and you
might sign up for being a commodity yeah
and then you get dumped on the street
the first time they decide they're going
to raise profits by decreasing payroll
that's called layoffs in Corporate
America for no reason other than
increase fishing profits
and they do it every day I've been
announcing them left and right like
crazy so that's the thing you don't want
to get into if you've got but if you've
got a solid company they're going to
treat you well you feel like your
enjoyment is there your your chances are
progressing in the field are just as
good or better
um you know you're never trade a pension
or benefits for that always take the
upside always yeah the per the uh
purported uh Security will always let
you down well I mean we have an
investment strategy that you've been
teaching for decades and it works and
that's what we're talking about here the
pay raise plus you using that strategy
you're gonna get further faster than the
pension ever would get you yeah I mean
50 Grand 750 in 15 years that'll that
adds up for you before you're eligible
for the pension you made an extra
three quarters of a million dollars yeah
that and that's not counting any raises
you would have gotten over and Beyond
what the federal government is going to
give you so take the job if all things
are equal that's the answer to the
equation yeah
so many people don't take the job
without making sure all things are equal
that's the issue like you gotta dig and
it's as simple as like talking to people
who work there talking to somebody who
knows somebody that works over there now
again you don't take one squeaky wheel
and say oh well this is a horrible
company you gotta get real feedback get
real mature people who are going to tell
you what it's like there and that is not
hard to find out but you got to be
intentional yeah I mean you can find
people that don't like anything yeah
that's right I guarantee you I mean we
we have an incredible culture and Ramsay
and Ramsay Solutions is a world-class
place to work but you can find people
that are pissed off I've read
nonsensical
straight up lies about our organization
as if I wasn't in the building I've read
this crap on social media and all that
people do this people squeaky wheels
will do that at any company not just
Ramsay any company and it's like you got
to talk to enough people to know whether
or not we got somebody who's angry or
somebody who's hurt or straight up crazy
because I've seen it all
yeah and you can find somebody
displeased with anything and some of
them have an agenda actually so anyway
the uh us included that's right and in
it that pleasure so don't just take one
that's right do your homework make sure
you're uh that you're not just trading
your soul for money
that's what you don't want to do but if
you can uh keep your soul and have a
great work environment and make more
money Yes Trade 50 grand for a pension
in about a nanosecond